hello folks welcome to rational science
I hope um my image is okay I hope my
voice is okay would appreciate anyone
letting me know how I'm coming out okay
into the screen okay so let me know as
soon as you can and if throughout the uh
lecture something goes wrong it's
because I have I'm using a different
computer I'm not familiar with it very
well
and so we'll find out what happens I
hope the class goes well today what
happened was that I gave my son ANS
uh my computer and he took off he went
to the states
and secret mission undercover work
and so um
I won't see that until October at least
and uh so let me know if uh if if
um if you can hear me okay and see me
okay okay
uh anyways a couple things first of all
I'll be uh on the road next week so I'll
probably postpone the next class
okay so be aware of that uh probably
will not happen on Sunday okay that's
one issue
and
um and so well you know uh I don't know
when I'll see you again maybe uh uh
sometime next week okay
okay so let's move on here
um first subject I want to touch upon is
um
again uh let me know if you can hear me
all right okay if you can see me all
right
okay again I'm using a different
computer
and
okay thank you thank you appreciate that
okay so uh let me talk about a a
different subject first which I rarely
talk about and that is sensitive okay
that's got very little to do with what
we talk about in this channel
but it turns out that they censored one
of my videos that I recently put up
there okay and I uh
um broadcasted it uh live okay and this
is the one day I found this note from
YouTube saying your content was removed
due to a file of our community
guidelines okay
and threaten me with a strike or really
they they were about to give me a strike
okay and I was supposed to review the
content then they sent me a second
message okay right after that
uh and it said something like uh morning
um content deleted by the user etc etc
you know it says content removed if this
happens again your channel will get a
community guideline strike
okay and I won't be able to do certain
things
okay so yeah uh it was quite threatening
what was the uh issue about
well
um
again this computer runs slow so I'm
gonna have to go a little slower here it
was about this uh video okay
uh Funny Thing Happened on the Way to
Mars
and it had to do very little with Mars
it had to do more with
um the fact that on that video uh I
mentioned uh
you know two words two words really
um the first word was uh autism autistic
autism right one of those and the second
uh word was that um
I was talking about homosexuals
and it's like if you say homosexual and
you say autism immediately the radar the
YouTube radar picks it up
and it's kind of dangerous because
immediately you have operators from
YouTube you know going in there and
trying to find out what you're talking
about and they use their own discretion
which is not always very good
and they send these messages out saying
hey you know uh you violated the
community guidelines
and so I challenged it uh you know I
said uh there's something wrong here you
know I mean I was just talking about it
scientifically a couple people ask
questions about I clarified my point of
view that I think that a lot of that has
to do with the fact that we lost genetic
diversity
and uh and what happened was they
approved my appeal in other words this
is what they sent me after that they
said hey I feel approved am I supposed
to
um
celebrate you know
uh
uh what am I supposed to do cheer drink
champagne
you know first they threatened me and
then they say okay you did okay uh we we
granted your appeal there was no reason
to to censor me in the first place
okay and uh what was I talking about
well I was talking about stuff like this
this is one aspect of it this is uh
something that I see happening uh lately
in in the in the world you have uh
reptiles that are born with two heads
okay and uh you say well is this normal
have we seen this in the past thousand
years back or is this a new phenomenon
that's happening
and here you see another version and
that's the mammals
here you can see some of these mammals
also have two faces two heads
and the question is uh why are some of
these animals coming out like this you
know why are they uh being born like
this and I'm saying it's got a little
bit at least to do with uh the fact that
they've lost their genetic diversity
okay so uh that was my whole argument
okay and so um you know I have no idea
why as soon as they hear words such as
autism or homosexuality they immediately
the radar picks it up and sends it to
you know to the people who to the judges
I think it's uh and especially when the
judges approve it that means they
haven't even watched the video because
if they would have watched it they said
okay he's just talking about something
scientific uh instead of just uh you
know sending you the message and then
saying oh call us back if if you want to
challenge it
okay and so uh what's the argument I've
touched upon that a couple times one
more time just in case so other people
know what I'm talking about this is
Calhoun's experiment and his experiment
consisted putting in a closing an
enclosure uh for couples of mice and he
allowed them to multiply
uh the four original couples were normal
they had children they had nesting
material they had all the food they
wanted
and the only thing that was really
missing uh they also were protected from
diseases and predators the only thing
that was missing is space okay they
didn't have space something we're going
to touch upon today we get to it if if
the system doesn't shut me down here and
uh you know what was the outcome of this
well the outcome is uh here you'll see
the chart let me make that a little
bigger
okay and uh this is this is what
happened the uh mice multiplied
and when they reached around uh 2000
uh funny came down to the point where
they became extinct and Calhoun was
saying that this might be a blueprint
for what has happened to humanity but
the big point that I saw is that he was
a psychology psychologist and uh he was
studying you know the effect of space on
the mind and so he was in a field
altogether but
um what struck me about his experiments
he did about 30 of them is that um
that the mice at the end he did it also
with rats became autistic and homosexual
so you could say that he's one first
person maybe even the first person to
have created uh
homosexuality in the lab
okay so I'm saying you know they had no
injections
uh people talking about injection they
had the same food you know it's not like
the food came from corporations that
that feed him some chemicals uh it was
all normal and uh so when people say
well homosexuality and
um autism they're the result of eating
or the foods we eat or the pollution or
uh injections and things of that nature
this is what they got to answer
this fellow produced homosexuality and
autism in the lab
without any of those factors without any
of those being variables okay so that's
what anyone who wants to address the
problem has to tackle okay he who
believes that it's the question of food
or a question of
you know injections or whatever uh
that's kind of like a political issue
more than a uh really scientific issue
man there's no reasoning not not too
much there could be a small effect but I
think the big effect here is
um the fact that you have uh the
enclosure you also have the founders
effect okay because they all came from
the same grandparents and I think that
that was the bigger issue that's the
underlying issue I think or the main
point the the main factor and
um I also had another video it wasn't
censored or I guess you could say it's
censored uh not censored in the sense
that I was in a warning or that they
gave me a strike but in the sense that
they said uh
that video we're not going to allow you
to put it for ads for where he's they're
not going to promote it for ads and it
was this one here okay
uh I made videos on the Neanderthal
series uh uh called it against at
mixture I'm saying humans and
Neanderthals never had sex
okay or maybe one guy out there might
have I doubt that even but the point
here was that I went through this whole
series and when I got to number 12 I
talked about rape
and these people heard the word rape and
immediately they uh put it you know it's
not uh for uh ads you know they they
censored it for ads essentially and just
because you talk about the word rape you
know yeah it is a four-letter word I'll
grant that but the issue here is that
you know I was talking about the fact
that
um Nando thoughts could not have raped a
human uh female for example a male
Neanderthal with a human female
um partly because of that video number
13 the one next to it you know shouting
distance you know the clan stayed
together not Venture far from uh the
clan because any animal could attack him
and kill them so I think that pretty
much he had to be more or less within
shouting distance or whistling distance
uh any member of the clan you could not
just wander off and so the chances of uh
there and I think that happened to all
monkeys in those days you know you just
can't stray too far from the clan and
what that means is that the chances of
something like rape happening I think
we're slim next to none
you know and so this is one of the
theories that is out there that's why I
wonder why they censored this one when
we're talking about a theory and this is
one of theories in the mainstream okay
they say that uh uh these uh
neanderthals maybe raped a woman you
know there was some pain uh
what do you call uh some
um things going on between and uh and
women
um
male male uh male neanderthals with
human females and maybe vice versa human
males with female uh
neanderthals and I don't think that
could have happened ever and part of the
reason is that we share no uh
mitochondrial DNA with an enderthals
that means we had no humans ever had
Neanderthal mothers according to that
study and no male humans had any white
chromosomes which is comes from the
males from from the male line okay and
so that kind of shuts down any
interaction with the Neanderthals at all
but since they had no theories for the
extinction of the Neanderthals they
created this nonsense that we had sex
with them and that because a smaller
population they kind of fizzled out in
our bigger population and what we have
today is a little bit of their
Neanderthal uh genes which just as well
or probably did come from when we
separated maybe 800 or so 100 000 years
ago okay so when when we separated with
them maybe even before then maybe with
the
um
heidelbergs maybe before that I I always
think that it's probably with Homo
erectus that this happened where Homo
erectus already was in England 800
000 years ago or some biped which which
is probably them okay and uh
and yeah if uh if there were some kind
of human in uh England 800 000 years ago
you're talking about maybe the level of
uh home Erectors intercessor Heidelberg
at best from the Neanderthals descended
of course we're going to have some uh
chromosomes and some not chromosomes but
some genes in common
and so I think that's why we have some
Neanderthal genes in us only because of
that other than that we never made it
after that uh two different species uh
too much time passed uh more than 500
000 years and so uh we were very
different not only in appearance which
already was scared the Daylights out of
any human and vice versa but uh you know
the chances of mating with them were
absolutely none and if there was
some hanky-panky going on between one
couple out of all those in those days I
don't think it would have created
you know the amount of
um uh
genetic similarities that we have like
two percent that we share with a
nandothal two or three percent
okay let's move on to another subject
this one has to do with a subject I've
been talking about lately and it's not
finished yet
it's The Ether okay what is The Ether
and I'm not talking about the stuff you
smell
okay I'm talking about this stuff uh
that people think is responsible or
underlies
um gravity underlies
electromagnetism maybe even light right
and when fellow says the following and
uh you know I like to define the ether
as uh
uh really an etherist I like to Define
an ether is as a person who doesn't have
the slightest clue what the ether is
that's the best definition of an
etherist because if he knew what the
ether was
he wouldn't be proposing the theories
that he proposes and here we have our
first uh etheris he says the black Sky
we see in The Ether made by threads and
ropes the black sky is made
meaning space you know it's made out of
threads and ropes I don't think so
change the word Matrix with ether so
they just say ethers everything
okay the Matrix is everywhere in other
words it's everything right it's like
God he's everywhere he's everything and
therefore
uh it's all around us even now In This
Very Room okay you can see it
uh bartender I would like to have
whatever he had you know uh uh you can
see it when you look at your window or
when you turn on your television okay I
don't know what what are you seeing but
I I don't see The Ether I see images of
different kind I can point to it at all
times
good if you can do it draw it very
simple you can point to it
draw it that's how simple it is and so
these people don't do that and uh that's
where I have a little bit of problems
with them
okay so here we have
um
uh different versions that you will find
you put this in um uh Google Images uh
you'll get something like this for The
luminiferous Ether okay and what do you
see well what you see is a bunch of
lines uh arrows okay and if you uh zoom
in on that okay you get something like
this more or less they all say the same
thing this is what they're all pointing
to
if I can get it up here it looks like
that that's your luminiferous ether okay
so if you ever wanted to know that's
what it looks like
and so what are you staring at well
you're staring at a bunch of points that
form arrows
and they're all going one way
and that's part of the problem right you
know they only ether can only go one way
and so you got to do kind of Miracles to
use this to explain both gravity and
electromagnetism that's one of the
issues okay it only goes one way okay so
what are we staring at what are those
arrows what are those points that make
up the arrows what is this
you know and that's part of the problem
uh and usually they're referring to
vector magnitude and Direction that's
what the arrows usually represent and
that means that they're going to be
doing math they're going to represent it
mathematically and put these arrows
uh ad hoc you know like here's my arrow
okay so are all the arrows The Ether are
all the points to Ether what's The Ether
and they never defined it they never
really pinpointed what the ether is in
other words they never drew it because
if it's a physical object you just throw
it that's how simple it is
and so he has to start at the beginning
what is The Ether I've already explained
this in the past and here you have uh
well
Abby let me get this right
okay there it is uh you have Mr
Aristotle there on the lower left
and uh what do you think of the ether
well all of them thought of them as
particles uh these were ether means air
it's the air of the Gods and they always
thought of air as particles
you know
um whether uh there was space between
the particles and whether there is
anything such as space whether space
exists and whether there is movement
whether the particle had a place to move
into these were the issues they uh
talked about you have to remember that
Democritus and even before him lucipus
um they were you know over 100 years uh
they came over 100 years before
Aristotle and so uh you know they
already discussed particles they said
all there is is atoms and empty space
atoms meaning particles This Is How They
viewed it and so they did talk about
particles in those days and they thought
of this as particles there was a debate
but they all debated about particles and
whether the particles had a place in
which to move so The Ether was thought
of as particles but as particles that
the gods breathe that's more or less a
notion
and certainly in the 19th century when
you have all these waves electromagnetic
waves they were trying to figure out
what light is what was it well it was
the undulation of all those particles
went up and down all these waves the
standing wave of particles that was more
or less the notion they had
and um that survived until today because
you have the quantum version okay
and this I can't remember exactly where
I got this from I'm sorry about that I
usually put the reference let's see the
Wikipedia or maybe uh even from
um from one of the uh physicists out
there mathematical physicists and what
is he saying they're saying modern
science does not equate vacuum with
nothing this can be important for the
next subject which is uh the Multiverse
okay so they're saying vacuum is not
always nothing or sometimes they do
sometimes they don't and some people do
equate the vacuum with uh nothing they
say that it's The Ether and some people
make a separation and think of space as
a container of ether and so you have to
be careful with which group you're
talking to you're talking about at least
The Ether right says indeed the vacuum
in Quantum field theory is filled with
what virtual particles okay so it's
filled that means that they separate or
they distinguish between the vacuum in
other words space
nothingness and uh what's in it which
are all these virtual particles and I'm
assuming if they're talking about
particles they're talking about some
kind of corpuscle and each one has to
have shape that means each one is
separated from the next one by what well
hopefully by space because they have to
identify what separates one particle
from another
and there you see that in the next slide
it says the quantum vacuum is often
viewed as a modern version of what an
ether Theory
so yeah the the quantum they never
abandoned The Ether The Ether is
survives until the day they call it the
space-time other people call it the
false vacuum or the quantum vacuum
they're talking about The Ether they're
talking about a space filled with
particles that's what ether has always
been
and then you see there it says a space
consists of selected what mathematical
objects that are treated as Point what
are points particles that's what they
mean but they use the word points
because they're going to talk about it
mathematically and mathematically what
is a point well it's a number a value
that's what a point is
and they say the nature of the points
can be widely it can be can vary widely
for example the points can be elements
of a set again what are they talking
about numbers functions on another space
or subspaces of another space now
they're talking about numbers they're
not talking about physics okay it is the
relationship that defines the nature of
space okay so you can see that Quantum
really treats
um
you know the vacuum is full of particles
and that's what the ether has always
been that's the notion of The Ether
Theory okay
here it is just to rub it in here we
have a Nobel Prize uh his uh name is
Robert Laughlin I've touched the bottom
a couple times and he says the policy
the modern concept of the vacuum of
space right vacuum of space I thought
vacuum in space were the same thing but
he said the vacuum of space confirmed
every day by experiment is a
relativistic ether but we don't call it
that because it is taboo yeah you can't
use the word ether but they've always
they never been either from the days of
the Greeks all the way to the day either
a bunch of particles it's always been
the same thing uh
some equate the particles uh the The
Ether with space others say no these
space contains the particles and others
like the other file the other day he
said no ethers neither ether is
potential
okay so we don't know what the ether is
and again I like to say that an etherus
is a person the best definition right is
an ether is is a person who does not
have the slightest clue what the ether
is and if you do know and he's going to
treat as an object he's just got to draw
it he's just got to put it up there for
us to see
okay and so uh here is uh the difference
for those of you who can't tell the
difference some people say that my
um threads my ropes they're The Ether I
haven't discovered anything new so here
I put them side by side so you can
distinguish if you have eyes you'll be
able to tell the difference here it is
the ether is the guy on the left and the
Rope model which is a single thread in
the entire universe that weaves all the
matter and all the Rope setting
interconnects every single and that's
the one on the right okay so is 100 left
the same thing as the one on the right
well hopefully you say no otherwise you
need to see an ophthalmologist okay you
got wrong with your eyesight okay so no
The Ether is not the same thing as the
Rope model we have no place for a bunch
of particles that's what the ether is if
you think these there is something
different
draw it don't tell me I'm wrong draw it
and that's exactly what this all said a
second a second fella he's been at this
for over a month he says
why the freak who the freak cares about
Greece thought on The Ether what The
Ether was I uh they never saw it either
yeah they never saw it they never
claimed to see it they didn't even know
what the what air was yeah they thought
of air as particles okay and that's
quite clear okay they didn't even know
what air was he says you're just as
stubborn arrogant as Despicable
narcissistic as your twin brother can be
there please come on at least they got a
little more hair than he does so long
Bill I'm subscribing well sorry to see
you go uh not because of the description
but because you are abandoning with your
tail between your legs I thought you
were going to take this to the
and to the end I thought we were gonna
really have a discussion here after all
I'm I'm
um you know uh
putting your your theory here you know
uh on the line and I'm discussing it
it's not like I'm avoiding your your you
know showcasing your theory and so you
know for him to abandon and leave and
run away with his tail between his legs
it's because he cannot answer the
questions okay and I've been you know
torquing the uh screw more and more
trying to get an answer from him and one
of the questions that I ask him is what
does The Ether look like I think it's a
valid question I'm asking you know if
you're going to treat ether as a
physical object you say it's a thing
okay draw it
illustrate it so that we know what
you're talking about what's going
through your head
saying it's a bunch of particles you say
that it ain't
don't raise uh strong men you know okay
we concede it you want to call The Ether
whatever you call The Ether no problem
make a picture of it show us what you're
talking about
well after one month he did come through
and he uh came with his ether blob
see if I can put this up here for you
this is the notion of The Ether okay
and he says That's The Ether here I'm
drawing ether for you
okay so here's the red ether blob that's
what he refers to as The Ether okay then
he explains he said The Ether goes in
the South Pole and comes out the West
Pole or the East pole I don't know one
pole and we're surrounding ether bends
back towards the South Pole again Taurus
okay in the case of a Magnus obviously a
loop in the case of gravity either goes
into an atom and exits and enters the
next atom and so on okay that's how he
visualizes this thing this is what
determines the flow of ether he's
talking about the flow of flow or what I
call the flow flu or the flu flow it's a
fluid flow or the flow or the fluid the
flu flow flu flow flow flu uh woodchuck
would chuck wood she sells seashells by
the seizure okay I'm back here okay uh
this is what determines the flow of
ether great and whatever medium that
pleases you no no it's not a pleasing me
you gotta tell the the story you're
you're giving the presentation okay and
of course how masses appear to attract
each other I've been working on this for
many years okay so what's the problem
what he's uh showing there well he's
showing three things at least if not
four let me
Point them out to you there's a blue
stuff
and he's saying that the ether is space
as well
so so there is no contrast between space
and ether because he's saying that space
and ether are the same thing so I even
need to know what the blue stuff is if
the red ether is both ether and space
what is the blue stuff then that serves
as contrast and of course they never
they never get to that point because
they say oh Bill you're just doing word
salad semantics now you got to tell me
what the black the blue stuff is because
you're giving your blob contrast
that's the first one the second one is
that you see those uh hexagons that
build the whole shebang which is the
whole blob if the whole Bob is The Ether
you got to tell me what each one of the
hexagons is not to mention each once the
lines that that comprises the hexagon
you gotta identify each one of those
things you can't just say there it is
you know you got you got too many things
in that picture you got to identify each
one okay and he doesn't do that and so
he says they're all one the blue stuff
the red stuff the hexagons the lines
that comprises of hexagons all of it is
The Ether
and yeah when you cover all the bases
you know uh so that nobody can challenge
your
um object the thing that you're
presenting your hypothesis which are the
objects that you must present and your
definitions if they're all the same but
yeah it's like God God is everything
and yeah you can do many things magic
many magic tricks if God is everything
if your blob is everything
and so yeah and this is his blob in
motion okay this is how he presented it
okay you can see how it's moving okay
and so you're saying yeah this this is
The Ether in motion and again we need to
identify what the blue stuff is we need
to identify what the uh hexagon r y one
hexagon is separated from another what
the lines are you can identify each one
explain each one or Draw each one
separately you know draw a line and tell
me what each line is draw a hexagon tell
me what a hexagon is and then draw The
Blob and the blue stuff identify those
as well and he doesn't do that of course
he says there's your blob now you want
to join there it is okay so we know what
it looks like more or less what he has
in the back of his mind
okay so what is the trick with this he's
got it playing what we asked him to
explain and that is this here we have
Okay
um
a spoon and I'm gonna let go of it and
it falls downwards we call that effect
that phenomenon we call it gravity okay
no biggie I think we're all familiar
with it here's an illustration of that
you see the spoon falling downwards
what does he have to explain well he's
got to explain why is the spoon coming
down in the case of gravity this is
gravity right and so you would think
that there's either push from above or
pull from below something is in contact
with a spoon that we can't see or touch
he's got to make that thing visible for
us because something is in contact with
a spoon otherwise otherwise we're
introducing black magic and saying it's
done by remote control God does it
Angels Do It Spirits do it okay you
can't do that not in physics the way it
works in physics you gotta make visible
the invisible intangible objects that is
pulling or pushing on the spoon and as
far as I'm concerned there's only push
or pull
okay but this uh fellow he invented a
new form where he thinks he invented a
new form of contact of physical contact
he calls it entrainment
what in the world is entrainment well
entrainment means push
that's you're carried with the with the
flow of you're in a river and a river
carries you because it's pushing on you
so he calls that push which he uh
equates with a Venturi effect where the
you know you have this constriction in
one place and that forces you to go
faster in a given region okay and he
calls that entrainment fine but
entrainment is pushed that's all it is
all you've done is push so you're not
pulling you're pushing you're just being
carried by the river and he never
understood that in his many years of
studying The Ether okay so he says no
it's neither push or pull it's in
treatment okay we call it push in
science okay and there it is uh he says
the spoon is being pulled downwards I
guess or pushed from above here I'm
illustrating pull because he says that
the um ether is between atoms so here
supposedly we have the atoms of the
Earth on the bottom and a spoon on the
top The Ether is between them and
somehow this entrainment this river is
pulling uh the spoon downers that's
that's the best I can explain it from
his point of view if he doesn't agree
with it well he can come back and
clarify for us what what I'm
interpreting wrong okay so I can't tell
you what is going through his mind all I
can tell you is that this is what he's
describing and again it's a description
and I'll tell you why
a second here
uh this computer works a little slower
okay
and here uh let me show you why because
this is the equation of the Venturi
effect Venturi effect has this equation
pressure
uh at a position one pressure at
position two density of the fluid right
and velocity of the fluids that's what
the equation is for the Venturi effect
what is all that that's just an equation
what's an equation a description
Venturi effect is not an explanation he
doesn't understand the difference
between an explanation and a description
and of course he's going to say Bill
you're just doing semantics you're just
doing word salad uh yeah what you have
is a description we have no explanation
of what causes what the mechanism is all
you're saying if I press here
it flows faster
there's more density over here and it
flows faster that's all you're saying
he's now explaining why it flows faster
he's just saying it does and that's the
Venturi effect it's just a description
mathematical description he never
understood that much like the flat
earthers they talk about you know um
gravity being density related
okay density is not an explanation
density is a description there's more
over here than over there
why does it go from more density to less
density or vice versa whichever one you
like
you gotta explain that you can explain
the flow of matter and hopefully the
matter doesn't just flow because it
likes to to flow it flows because
something is pushing on it or pulling on
it if you don't put push or pull if you
don't have physical contact you're doing
black magic
that's as simple as that okay okay so
what did I ask this father to do and he
hasn't done that so again I got to do it
for him because he says the blob this
ether thing is between two atoms okay so
I put two atoms in there and I said okay
what show me what's in between the atoms
okay so he's gonna put his ether blob
okay
here it is
that's what he put in there okay he's
put his blob okay so I said okay let's
see same with this he's gonna pull uh
produce pull I guess uh because one atom
goes towards the other I would think
that's pull I'm not sure how you can
turn this into push
okay uh here's another version of this
give me a second here
okay maybe it's like that sideways okay
I don't know how he's gonna put his blob
it's up to him to tell me how he wants
his blob put in there
just in case I did push as well okay
here's push
okay the the blobs are on the outside
pushing uh each particle inwards I don't
know if this is the one that he's
referring to probably not okay just in
case I have another version of that one
as well here it is
okay
uh hold it here it is ah give me a
second
like that okay so you have all these
versions of push and pull
just in case you know I put another
version yeah here it is where the uh two
particles are within the blob okay
so maybe it's something like this and
again I all I can do is look at the
possibilities based on what he explained
and he says so far all we have a
description we have no idea why one
particle is pulled towards the other he
says I put the blob in there it's
self-evident do you understand no we
don't okay we don't understand because
you haven't produced it you haven't
shown me why one particle is going
towards another especially in a straight
line rather than going around that's one
issue uh here's another version of this
one just in case so you know I try to
cover all the bases
give me a second here
okay that's another version of it
I don't know which one he wants it's up
to him I don't know if he's got a
version that I have not put here uh
here's a third version of this okay like
that maybe
I don't know what else to do I'm I'm
putting it in every way that I can
imagine that he's gonna produce uh
um
pull or push I don't know I guess he's
doing pull of some kind or maybe they're
pushing from the outside I don't know
he's got to tell me which of these
scenarios is the one that he proposes
and I want to clarify one more time the
black stuff that you see in the
background he says that's ether too it's
a static ether while the other ether
moves it's like we have a shearing
effect where you have the black which is
standing still and the other ones that
move uh he has to justify that he says
it's all the same stuff
which clearly it ain't
again you see the hexagons you see the
lines making up the hexagons all that's
got to be uh clarified you know what he
means by each one of those things
because these are all different things
and so he's got like four different
things there aside from the atoms he
says the atoms are also made of the
stuff so there is no difference between
The Ether and the particles also even
though he's got a shearing effect
between the black stuff and the stuff
that's moving the red and blue stuff
there so I don't know it's up to him
he's he's the guy who's got to tell us
what his mechanism his proposed
mechanism is I cannot put words in his
mouth he's got to put words you know in
into the into the screen so that we can
see his mechanism
okay and all I can do is illustrate what
he's talked about and that's all I can
do okay so here
we go back to his uh original and there
it's not in motion but this is the blob
this is what he presented I took a
snapshot of it as opposed to it running
because we need to First identify the
object we can always put it in motion
later on and you can see that what he's
got to identify he's got to identify the
blue stuff The Blob the whole shebang of
the red stuff he's got to identify the
hexagons that form uh the many hexagons
that form the blob and also the six
sticks that form each one of the
hexagons but at least a hexagon's got to
be justified that at least if he doesn't
want to justify the stakes we can let
them off the hook but he's got to
justify the hexagons and the blue stuff
okay and so the ball is in his court and
I think it'll be forever in this court
because he put his tail between his legs
and
started running okay
okay let's get into the subject matter
today which is the Rope model of the
Multiverse and before I can get to that
I gotta again compare
and contrast the uh official version of
the Multiverse against the one from the
Rope model because they're different and
I want you to see that difference
because that's essentially the main
point of the lecture today
so I start with this fellow and his name
is Larry Kraut I think that's his name
there he say well he says a universe
from nothing
what is he referring to
well he says he can build matter
something from nothing
and he's got the process he's got the
mechanism he's got the causes and boy am
I interested in this subject if you can
produce something from nothing
especially without God but I'll even
concede God I'll put God in there no
problem I'll let you have God
I want God to go to his garage
to his Workshop right and show me how he
builds something from nothing in one
frame
single frame you know from one frame to
the mix here we have nothing and in the
next frame suddenly we have something I
want to know the mechanism and there's
no frame in between because we went from
uh nothing to something
and I want to see what the mechanism is
and I'm not sure you can produce a
mechanism without a frame in between
so I have a problem with suddenly you
know something popping out of nothing
but that's what he his book is about you
say how's he going to explain this I
mean obviously he's trying to sell a
book okay that's his main point but you
know how do you do this this is this is
quite a miracle and so I was interested
in finding out because let me tell you
what the issue is the issue is that
we're going to have a Multiverse
what separates one Universe from another
and you can't say space because space as
far as I'm concerned doesn't have a
fence where space stops and something
else continues you know
as far as I know I mean but he who
proposes that has to illustrate defense
okay so you got to put a fence there at
the end of space and then tell me what
continues we'll continue another space
there's a fence dividing one space from
another
so how can you talk about a universe
when as far as I'm concerned universe is
space and matter that's that's the
universe otherwise you got to define the
word Universe before you
talk about multi versus
multi-universe multiple universes okay
so that's the train of thought here okay
okay
and so he said uh something from nothing
he's going to create a universe from
nothing meaning he's going to create
matter and space from nothing I thought
space was nothing but apparently uh good
old Larry she has a different View and
so we have to look at this word nothing
what is nothing especially we're going
to be separating one Universe from
another with this nothingness what is
this nothingness okay and how is it
different learn space which I thought
was nothing
so yeah we got to get to the bottom of
this word nothing and so we look it up
and it's what we see
says nothing nothing or no thing and
they have different ways of saying tank
rate is the complete absence of anything
the opposite of everything or its
compliment
well all the all that they did and this
is out of the Wikipedia is
um put an antonym they say nothing is
the opposite of something and something
something or anything is the opposite of
nothing and so we have no definition of
either one or we have antonyms okay and
antonyms like synonyms they're circular
definitions in other words no definition
at all we have no definition of the word
nothing
early Greek philosophers argued that it
was impossible for nothing to exist well
there I have to be on their side yeah
nothing cannot exist because only
objects can be said to exist you cannot
say that space exists or that nothing
exists or that vacuum exists because
what do you mean by exist then
and yeah the atom is a lot atomus by the
way uh Democritus and um lucipus right
the atom is allowed nothing but only in
the spaces between the invisible
invisibly small atoms for them all space
was filled with atoms and again you're
talking about space being filled
and again this is where the notion of
space as a container arises they treat
spaces oh we're filling space like you
fill the notion with with uh fish and
they're displacing this container or
this medium called space No Such answer
you you don't fill space you do not uh
display space space has no
um surface so it's not like you're
pushing space all the way to the edge of
space where another medium contain
continues
so yeah this notion of filling space
that's what's irrational you got to
define space before you can say that in
space is nothing and nothing what is
nothing well uh obviously if they say
that's the opposite of something or
anything or or what or a thing well then
we got a problem okay because then uh
nothing is the opposite of
uh something and what is something well
let's uh no no nothing that's what
something is no nothing we have just
negatives
okay Aristotle took the view that there
exists matter and there exists space
again there exists space no space cannot
be said to exist a receptacle in other
what a container of some kind into which
matter objects can be uh or material
lives can be placed okay yeah again
space is not a container and space
exists are you kidding me
and and that's because they didn't
Define these words that's the issue it
is word sounded what they're doing not
what I'm doing I'm trying to Define
these terms so we can talk rationally
they never Define that they they're
doing word salad or or failing to do so
meaning they're failing to define words
and uh
and here you have this became the
Paradigm for classical scientists when
in the days of Newton from then on you
know scientific revolution of the 17th
century Descartes argued against the
existence of empty space until the
scientific discovery of a what a
physical vacuum
talk about an oxymoron all they said a
physical something vacuum nothing so we
have a something nothing that's what a
physical vacuum is
so yeah these people just put words in
there what we call word salad okay that
is a play of words and why because they
never defined any of them that's why
they can get away with this nonsense
okay and what is space I mean that was
nothing and space is not nothing so what
is space if it's not nothing well let's
find out space in with Street values
coordinates are required to determine
the position of a point
that's a space
what's that got to do with physics all
they're saying is look we have three
what not chord it's called number lines
they have all these three number lines
and detain they determine a point which
is what a position or a point which is a
number
that's what they're talking about
they're saying look it's a uh
a pair uh ordered pair or an order
triplet or a quadruplet or whatever and
what they're talking about is how to
locate something with coordinates really
meaning by number lines
and more commonly it is defined as
three-dimensional euclide euclidean
space
and space Etc that I mentioned n equals
three that models physical space again
to something nothing a space is a set
set what is a set sometimes called the
universe so now they they have a
universe okay we have the set the space
the universe they put it all Bunch it
all together with some added structure
what structure there's no structure in
math well modern mathematics uses many
types of spaces such as euclidean spaces
linear spaces topological spaces Hilbert
space the probability spaces they have
all these spaces it does not define the
notion of space itself
so they have no definition of the word
space but they use the word space they
say oh yeah we we locate points within
space with three number lines
and what do you mean by space oh we
don't know we just locate points if in
space that's what we say so they treat
it as a container as a physical object
and they're only talking about math how
to locate a point using number line
three numbered lines in this case
sometimes they use two number lines for
the typical Cartesian coordinates okay a
space consists of selected what
mathematical objects what the hell is a
mathematical object what is it number
five is that a mathematical object and
equations that are mathematical object
that are treated as points yeah numbers
that's what they're talking about and
selected relationships between these
points these numbers that's what they're
talking about the nature of the points
can vary widely for example what what
are they the points can be elements of a
set meaning numbers functions of another
space median equation or subspaces of
another space meaning numbers of numbers
subsets of uh of numbers
it is the relationship that
so we have a problem here because these
people don't Define their terms they use
the word liberally they use words of
ordinary speech they say well you know
what I mean I'm talking about space Oh
yeah okay I know what you mean
and what they're talking about is two
coordinates meaning two number lines or
three number lines or four number lines
necessary to locate a point where within
space which is a container which they
can't Define which they don't know what
it is they don't they never Define it
but they said we're going to use the
word because we like to work and somehow
that
crosses the boundary into physics and
now they're talking you know they
started with math they end up talking
about physics and saying oh we can tell
you what the universe is like because
the physical world is represented in the
language of math
that's the whole story that's the whole
that closes the circle
okay so what's the problem with Larry
well here let some other people talk for
me okay here's uh one Fawn his name is
David Albert he's a
physicist isn't mathematical physicists
who went into uh philosophy really and
he says the following he criticizes what
Kraus says about nothing he said the
main theme of the book is the claim that
we have discovered that all signs
suggest a universe that could and
plausibly did arise from a deeper
nothing
involving the absence of space itself
okay so space is not nothing uh space is
different so uh space came into being
from nothing okay yeah I understand
everything and which may one day return
to nothing we go from space to nothing
okay by a processes that may not only be
comprehensible but also processes that
that do not require any external control
or Direction physicist David Albert said
the book failed to live up to its title
you know uh Universe from nothing his
Larry's now misuse of the term nothing
absolutely it if matter comes from
relativistic Quantum Fields the question
becomes where did those fields come from
which Krauss does not discuss
if you look at his book okay at least
from the analysis that I've seen I
haven't read the book I don't care to
read it because obviously it's nonsense
it's Poppy cooked he's going to equate
Fields with nothing
and say there was Fields there were
Fields out there
and from the fields we have space
what is space a bunch of particles that
are made of fields vibrating Fields
Butterfields nothing
that's more or less a strain of slot and
so you say holy what are these fields
where do they come from uh that's
nothing so I don't have to justify that
is the nothing
that's more or less his argument and
here the New York Times also did an
analysis and it puts it clearly where I
just mentioned certain Arrangements of
the fields for instance correspond to
there being 14 particles in the universe
this is what this is out of his book uh
Larry Crouch's book and certain other
arrangements corresponding to there
being 276 particles and certain other
Arrangement correspond to there being an
infinite number of particles okay so we
have countless particles great and
certain other arrangements correspond to
there being no particles at all okay no
particles at all okay so what what do we
have if we have no particles and those
last Arrangements there were no
particles at all are referred to in the
jargon of quantum field theories so he's
saying look there are no particles what
you have as fields
okay what are these fields for obvious
reason as vacuum States so you're saying
a vacuum State consists of fields fields
are not particles
even though you have Sean Carroll saying
that particles of the vibration of
fields local vibrational Fields right
because he's trying to explain how
space-time is related to Quantum right
and so here we continue this Crouse
seems to be thinking that these vacuum
states must amount to the relativistic
quantum field theoretical version of
there not being any physical stuff at
all
so he's saying these fields are nothing
so he doesn't have to justify it because
he's reached the end of the line he says
I'm there already I've proven that space
and matter came out of nothing but it's
nothing a bunch of fields what it feels
nothing and that's why I don't have to
justify it I already prove my point
you missed it and he has an argument or
thinks he does that the law is a
relativistic Quantum field theories
entail that vacuum states are unstable
okay so who cares and that in a nutshell
is the account he proposes for why there
should be something rather than nothing
so he doesn't start from nothing he
starts from fields and equates those
fields with nothing
and he says these vacuum states are
unstable
meaning they're already in motion
because they're unstable
and so what is it that is in motion and
he says it's nothing because fields are
nothing even though you have Sean
Carroll saying well fields are something
the vibrations are fields are what
particles are which is what fills space
and we call them virtual particles
because they can come in anytime they
want at the uh uh request of a
mathematician ad hoc you know just pull
it in whenever you need it briefly so
that you can't measure it or detect it
and it goes back to be in space again
and so what are these fields well fields
are space
so are they something or nothing do they
have shape or not or what are we talking
about you know are they just vectors
well what are we talking about and so
yeah they never illustrate their
theories because they can't that's the
issue just like the etherists they can't
illustrate their Theory because as soon
as they Illustrated you pin them against
the
uh chords and start pounding them yeah
okay so here's uh another fellow his
name is uh Neil Tyson and he does most
uh the same thing he proposes the same
thing as well as Max tag Mark and some
of these other fellas
um Brian Green and so on our minds
cannot fathom the idea of a Multiverse
yeah you cannot because you you have no
way of separating one clump of matter as
I call it from another if they all share
the same space and what is universe
space and matter and so unless you can
put a fence between one universe and
another you can now talk about
Multiverse many universes Quantum
fluctuations would be responsible for
another Universe having slightly
different laws of physics than ours yeah
great you got to separate and not tell
me about laws you got to tell me
physically what separates one Universe
from another not tell me that they have
different laws of physics okay you you
have Justified that you're just talking
out of your ears you know nose holes new
universes are creative forming an
endless number of Worlds yeah that's
great statement you got to tell us what
separates from one Universe from another
and we have to distinguish a little bit
here between the Multiverse to some
degree and the many worlds
version of quantum mechanics which is
for every step you take you Branch off
into a different universe
and that's only a way of eluding the
question
people say well why did this happen and
they said well in this universe
but in Another Universe something else
happened here you won the lottery over
there you lost the lottery
so they don't have to explain anything
they just have to say you just Branch
out in different universes why because
they're talking about statistics they're
saying statistically all these things
could have happened and they all did
happen because Quantum allows for all of
them to happen if they all did happen
they can't happen in the same universe
they have to happen in separate
universes
and that's a little different than
saying physically there are all these
clumps of matter we'll call this one
Universe one this one Universe two this
one Universe three and we have the
Multiverse which means that you have to
tell me what separates with Universe
from another where's the fence what is
the fence tell me what separates one
Universe from another and we all share
the same space it's just one Universe
because universe is matter and space
okay and that's where you got to begin
definitions
and again here um
yeah we have uh uh this phone uh Robert
lofling against us for you reminding you
again that they talk about The Ether so
what is space space is ether bunch of
particles that's what it's always been
nothing's ever changed so if space is a
bunch of particles which is what he's
saying there or space contains countless
particles it's all filled with space
with particles and these particles the
vertical ones at least can pop into the
real world whatever that means from the
non-real world you know and for a brief
period of time so that they affect
something that you can't measure and
then go back well that's great it's
something you can't prove you can't
measure and they just say it is so
because we have no other way of
explaining our equations
okay I see how it is uh you just do ad
hoc things you put them in by hand okay
great
okay so uh that's what space is it's
full of particles okay so um I don't
care if it's full of particles you got
to tell me what separates one Universe
for another from another if you're going
to talk about the Multiverse okay and
um
so once again I show you the difference
between The Ether world of quantum
mechanics which is the same one they've
always had a bunch of particles and a
single thread because I'm going to
contrast my uh Multiverse from theirs
and I'm going to say that a single
thread comprises all the matter in one
Universe why is it one Universe it's one
Universe because all the matter made by
that thread weaved by that thread every
atom and every rope that connects every
atom is made of a single thread and it's
a closed loop thread so anything that is
not attached to it comprises you can say
a different Universe the problem here is
that you have to separate one Universe
from another and you can't because you
got to put a fence around space then you
can separate one Universe from another
and so uh what you what you have to do
is put either the fence or say there's
only one universe
so what is that single thread well it
forms a clump of matter well that's the
best word I can come up with you can
call them an island whatever you want to
call it you can call it island or Clump
and we have one thread it makes up all
the matter in our universe but it's not
connected none of those atoms are
connected to the atoms of another
universe that's the idea okay so uh what
we have is something that um
uh but we've got to begin with a
definition so let's begin there first so
that we have it in the right context
okay this is the definition of something
that which has shape what is an object
uh thing entity substance those are
synonyms of the word something what is
nothing that which doesn't have shape
synonyms there you m space vacuum void
nothingness
what is Universe something and nothing
so it includes the nothing
Universe includes Space Universe
includes uh nothing includes vacuum you
can't get away from that because
otherwise you either have matter or you
have nothing you have space
if you want to talk about Universe you
got to put them both together that's
what the word Universe means okay we
have the definitions okay you get some
other definition no problem you got to
defend them you got to bring them up say
this what universe is is what nothing is
this is what something is no problem you
gotta put them out there and defend them
against attack and I have no problem
attacking you believe me I love it just
like attack the ethers the flat earthers
electric universers and the mainstream
I'll Attack you too okay if you don't
follow those definitions I need to know
why you need to defend those definitions
again say well it is so because I like
it and my brother likes it as well just
the fact that you your brother voted for
your definition doesn't make it so you
gotta defend it
okay so here's our uh version of the
Multiverse okay we have all these
threads and of course uh each one of
those uh forms all the matter comprised
by one of those threads okay so each one
is separated from the others that's the
only thing I want to show here okay so
you have each one of these threads they
have in our universe you can say the one
on the upper left there that's our
universe and um it's a certain size I
guess you could say it has a certain
amount of thread maybe the laws of diff
uh physics that they say are different
in other words maybe the speed of light
is different from the other universes uh
maybe the atoms are a different sizes
different masses Etc that could be if
we're made of different amounts of
thread but this would be the notion of
the multi-universe uh in the Rope
version but what we're talking about is
not multi-universe you're talking about
a single universe but you're talking
because they all share the same space
because you can and put a fence around
space the thread there that you see is
not a fence I'm just putting it there so
that you can see this and here let me
show you uh you would held these clumps
of matter and again you got to forget
about the thread okay the only reason I
put the thread is you can see it better
but what you're saying is look all these
atoms in one Universe are all connected
to each other and they're all made of a
single closed loop thread which is not
connected to any of the others
the universe is one the clumps of matter
Island whatever you want to call those
uh those are you could say
multi-universe multi-clumps
multi-islands and within their within
each one you have uh galaxies within
each one you have stars and so on that's
the notion that we have uh for the
rope version rope model of the
Multiverse okay
and so uh this takes us to our
conclusions first uh let me show you
what the conclusions are for the
establishment they never Define the word
universe that's a big round they never
Define the word space
or matter for them and they have no idea
what any of these words mean they just
use them ordinary speech they say you
want to know what they are Look in the
dictionary or go ask uh
what is a philosopher a physics or a
English major librarian you know any of
those
they treat the universe as a thing they
treat space as a thing they treat them
as both as a nothing and as a thing they
treat us both something and nothing and
that's why they get away with murder
okay uh Universe out of nothing
according to Larry
um yeah we got a problem there because
he he says it comes out of fields not of
nothing and he of course he's going to
elude the word field and that destroys
his entire book which is out there only
for to make money that's it because of
his name because he's more or less a
celebrity in the world of mathematical
physics physic being too big for him
expanding Universe uh what is that what
is expanding its space
it's this dark energy that's blowing
everything apart what is that dark
energy what is that space well it's
something what's it pushing against it's
an unscientific question because we
don't know uh you know where the
universe ends it's like asking what's
north of the North Pole you're what are
you talking about here you're talking
about what's outside of space and why is
it an irrational question according to
them it's because
um we have no way of proving it so it's
not really so much of an irrational
question it's a unscientific question a
philosophical question because we have
nowhere verifying what's outside of
space
no no it's very simple draw space and
and we'll know what's outside when you
identify it in your picture then we'll
know what's outside of space you have to
tell the crowd not say hey guess what's
outside of space and yeah we can't prove
it because we can't go outside of space
not even God can step outside of space
because he's got no boundary to cross so
to say outside of space is irrational
because space is that which has no shape
it has no boundary for even God to cross
poor fellow is looking for the end of
space he's still trapped in here with
all of us
so whether this unit multi-universe mean
well it really means under the Rope
model right it means Islands clumps of
matter but we all share the same space
but under the
um
mainstream version until they define
space until they Define the word
universe will never have a clue what
they're talking about when they say
Multiverse they talk about the different
laws of physics they don't talk about
physical separation which is what we
need if we're going to talk about
multi-universes and uh how does it
related to the fourth dimension only God
knows okay and God's into Fifth
Dimension okay and so here's the
conclusion for the counterpart the Rope
model okay here you have it uh we have
the single thread model of the universe
that's the whole universe as far as
we're concerned but there's nothing
wrong nothing preventing us from having
multi-threads okay uh each one of those
comprises uh an island a clump of matter
okay uh the threat is an object so we're
talking about something physical now
we're not talking about mathematical
Concepts such as field and energy and
any of that
um
we could have many single threads out
there
uh they're unconnected that's why
they're you know they're remember
they're closed loop threads they're
unconnected to each other so none of
those atoms from that Universe are
connected to any of the atoms in our
universe so we have each one is made of
its own single thread okay and we could
have different speeds of light different
masses for the atoms all that kind of
stuff uh what does exist well it's
object press location
so uh we have an object it's called a
single thread does it have location
well the only way it can have location
if there are other clumps
or single threads out there okay and
yeah we can say that we can speculate
and say yeah there are other clumps of
matter out there our universe can be
said to exist following the definition
right strictly because uh you know one
universe is uh has location with respect
to another universe and these universes
are are disconnected from each other
okay so no problem there and so we can
use the word exist in that context
otherwise it's irrelevant we're talking
about existence of uh matter within our
universe and for that all you have to
have one object any atom or anything
made out of atoms having location with
respect to another group of atoms that's
it
um we won't figure it out you know
through any test or experiment this is
just a you know an entertaining issue to
ponder a philosophical issue could there
be other universes out there well it's
it's something to kick around at the
water cooler nothing more than that you
know it's uh we'll never figure it out
this is just speculation and it's nice
to talk about it no more than that it's
not like we said oh I'm going to prove
to you that there are other universes no
such monster and in that sense it
doesn't mean it's unscientific it just
means it's nice to talk about it nothing
more than that
okay let me get to some of the questions
and comments that people made since last
time okay here's uh one fellow I know
this one this one is someone put the uh
uh to the chat GPT they put something
about light and the thread whether the
ropes the threads you know whether light
could be a thread or vibration of a
thread or something along those lines
here it is he says down at the bottom
how does light work what could transmit
a signal going from both directions
between all atoms at a constant speed of
roughly 300 000 kilometers per hour the
formula for speed is the wavelength of
the object multiplied by its frequency
you know uh it's a a wave equation
so what did chat GPT or smart computers
or robots they're uh reply well here it
is
uh says it took all the conditions that
this all put into consideration and
there you have it at the bottom he says
uh let's imagine a vast interconnected
web of ultra thin almost invisible
threads that stretch between all atoms
these threads vibrate at different
speeds and lengths and the vibrations
travel along the threads at a constant
speed when an atom plucks the thread the
vibration travels along it interacting
with other atoms it's connected to the
speed of the vibration is determined by
how tight or loose the thread is which
corresponds to it wavelength and
frequency
so it did not explain it just what it
what the chat GPT did was give us a
description of what would happen if we
simulate light with a thread that is the
way I guess Chad GPT understood it is uh
if the thread
um has a standing wave of sorts so they
said you have this thread you wave it up
and down you have the oscillations it
travels at a certain speed but see they
were able to use that to come to the
equation
uh the wave equation of uh little C it's
velocity of light 300 000 kilometers per
second uh equals the frequency times
wavelength where when each one is
um uh you know opposite the other when
one rise of the other one uh they're
inversely proportional when one goes up
the other one goes down and so chat GPT
answer the question at least from a
descriptive point of view without any
problem so it means the model works okay
now whether you believe in it or not
that's a separate issue but Chachi PT
already is on record saying the Rope
model works okay and it didn't do the
robe it did the thread but it should be
a rope really but no problem get close
close enough uh the guy asked the
question through threads
okay uh here we have a first question or
a common person first that says you your
step number one is hypothesis yes in a
scientific method right why do you
purposely avoid observation
using one of your human senses yeah
observation eyes you know you see right
um
as a logical First Step you you're
actually anyone's method right missing
this simple obvious might put your
entire work Under Suspicion
well we're not here for belief okay so
it's not a question of suspicions the
question is do you understand okay and
it's a pity
well what's the problem with this fall
he uses the word observation he talks
about observe he says don't you have to
observe something before
before you can start science
or physics you know the answer is no
okay
guy comes to the blind
uh death
quadruple well I'm not deaf let's make
them here but we'll kind of say that
he's blind and he's quadriplegic he
never touched he never saw
okay so we have no observation no
touching no tangibility
and a guy comes to the stage this blind
quadriplegic Sage you know and says look
let's imagine the situation in the land
of the Klingons and we have let go of a
spoon and it always falls to the ground
what could be causing that
and the guy explains that he said the
sage he says look maybe all atoms in the
spoon are connected to every atom in the
klingon's planet that make up this
Klingons planet and maybe as they fall
you know the uh these extensions they
fan out and the you know as it falls it
falls faster and faster and faster
there's an acceleration of gravity
he explained something he never saw
something he never touched we do not
need observation in fact the way we do
it in science and please learn it well
we do it the mafia way the gangster way
we kill the witness we do not observe
anything we do not witness anything we
do not testify to anything the first
thing we do is kill the Observer
so no it's the other way around Observer
is the first thing we eliminate from
science from physics because every time
everybody introduces your Observer
meaning what did you measure well this
is what I measure I don't give a hoot
what you measured explain the mechanism
that's what we want and we don't have to
be seeing or touching anything
the guy can just say say let me tell you
what I what I imagined
I imagine a cow falling from the sky
falling on the earth what could be
causing that and I give you a cause I
give you a mechanism for for that
phenomenon you just it described but
done you don't have to observe anything
at all okay so no observation is not
part of the scientific method the
mathematicians put it in their why
because without observation meaning
measurement
uh they cannot introduce experiments
what is the purpose of experiments to
convince people to persuade them it's
introduce it as evidence you know you do
an experiment now what are you going to
do with that you're going to introduce
it as evidence to convince the jury so
the only purpose of experiment
observation is to persuade not to
explain that's why it's not part of a
scientific method
okay here we have another fellow and he
says the following
if ropes deform how can they be one
piece
uh-huh to deform different parts of an
object move independently from another
okay if there are Parts those parts need
to be held together ropes aren't
tangible to themselves but they seem to
be tangible to atoms so why aren't atoms
Tangled in their robes I would like to
know the mechanism that makes something
intangible tangible
but this time before I was talking about
religion we're not talking about science
uh what's the issue here the issue is
the thread is made of a single piece and
we postulate we hypothesize that's what
it's called we make the assumption
let's repeat those words because he
doesn't understand what I just said
we're going to make an assumption a
supposition we're going to hypothesize
what other synonyms are there we're
going to make believe
okay that the thread is made of a single
piece and it has the property of being
flexible why because those are the
properties we see in our world today in
a world today uh we have a single thread
and this thread makes up every atom and
the Row setting to connect them and all
these atoms are able to wiggle with
respect to one another and the only
thing different between a solid and a
liquid and gas is the fact that uh the
amount of movement they have the amount
of flexibility
but uh the thread has all those
properties that's why it's not an
unreasonable assumption to say that the
thread is flexible
okay and uh can become rigid between two
atoms in the form of a rope why because
if you lower the frequency meaning
you've got something very very cold the
colder it is the less frequency there is
and uh the less it moves
okay so yeah the thread is flexible and
can turn into something rigid okay and
there is no process there is no
mechanism that's where it's religion
what he's talking about he's trying to
come up with a why why God made it that
way that's what he's trying to talk
about that's what he's saying
essentially why did God make the thread
flexible and made of a single piece yeah
it's not made of Parts it's not made of
atoms it's not made of little points or
particles or segments or whatever you
want to call them it's made of a single
piece but it is flexible that's an
assumption that's what it's called okay
and there's no y to an assumption it
just is
okay why is it is because it's an
assumption you say I'm going to give it
these properties and from that we're
going to build our Theory
now if you don't like the assumptions
then you have to question the
assumptions and no problem you can
question the assumption but I'm not sure
how far you're going to get because
we're saying let us assume
and you say well I don't want you to
assumption well you don't want my
assignment I'm sorry that you want to
understand the theory that's founded
upon that assumption that's the way it
works in science so there is no why to
it because why you're just asking why
did God make it flexible and made of a
single piece
it just is
there's there's a beginning to a theory
and it starts with hypothesis that's how
it works and you have to have the
definitions you have to have the
properties of the thread and we've got
all of those so I'm not sure what his
problem is he's just thinking in terms
of three-dimensional world where we have
today that water is flexible and Isis
not
and you say okay why because they're all
made of particles and why is this one
flexible wire and that one not uh
flexible and the the issue is the
following he doesn't understand that
there's something between them because
there's this wave and they're saying
that when the wave has high frequency
then it's flexible when it has very low
frequency meaning long wavelength then
it's rigid and he doesn't understand
that that's the first thing he's got to
go in research before asking the
question he's never done that he doesn't
understand that that there is something
between two atoms except that the
mathematicians the people of quantum
they say it's a wave it's a field
and he's he's okay with I say okay it's
a field now I understand now you haven't
understood anything because as we just
discussed no one understands what a
field is field is a bunch of numbers
that's what a field is you can't see
them feel the numbers are rigid or more
flexible
so you can't use the word field or
energy to explain that you got to put a
physical object and say this one's rigid
and this one's loose that's the way it
works and we put a rope in there and say
look if the frequency is low it's cold
it's rigid frequency is high
Heat
it's flexible
okay and last one here follow talks
about the shadow uh saying he's got
shape he says of course I meant that the
part of the shadow on the surface in
other words the shape of the
cross-sectional projection of the uh
ball outline not the shadow in the
middle of 3D space the ball indeed has
shape great ball is 3D it has shade yeah
hopefully uh but he's saying that the
shape is the circle like from your
Vantage Point of View you just see a
circle okay uh that isn't the same thing
as the shape to which I refer okay what
are you referring to Mucho is that Globe
is not the same as the flat map
projection
all he's saying again in different words
run around and saying the same thing
he's saying look shape refers to 2D form
refers to 3D and I've already explained
let's go through them again
uh English is probably the only language
on the planet
where there's a difference between a
word shape and a word form everybody
just uses the word form in other
languages at least most of the ones I
know about
uh that's one issue they only have the
word form then I showed the other day
that the word shape is a perfect
definition a perfect synonym of the word
form and vice versa form means shape
shape means form there is no difference
between them especially in physics so to
say well a circle has shape and a sphere
has formed is nonsense that's his notion
of it that's not what the book says
that's not what the dictionaries say and
that's certainly not what physics says
and one of the reasons physics doesn't
say that is that if you're going to make
a presentation
and I'm going to show you
uh I don't know for example a wave
now we're talking about mathematical
physics and I show you a wave and a wave
is obviously 3D you know because you
have the
um magnetic field perpendicular to the
um
electric field so obviously you have 3D
there alone
and they always put it in 2D because you
know I can put that in in a 2d platform
what are you going to say oh no I'm not
going to allow you to do that because
you're talking about 2D and there's no
such thing as a 2d in physics
now the guy is making uh 2D
representation of a 3D object like if
you put a cube there and you say look
it's this is a cube and you put the
protection now what's what's coming from
from the screen is 2D it's just a flat
Square uh or a rectangle of some kind
but it's a you say look that's a cube
and we give it projection with the Mind
what's coming out of the screen is too
deep but what's in your minus 3D you say
okay I see what you think I was trying
to say and the same thing goes for the
wave the wave is 3D but you put a 2d
wave because you're explaining something
are you not going to allow the person to
talk and say oh because that has shape
but it doesn't have form so now I'm not
gonna let you give the presentation
see by using the word shape if anything
it covers both form and shape assuming
you were right and shape only refers to
2D because 2D is part of the 3D
and by saying shape or 2D you're
covering every all the all the shapes
all the objects in the universe by
distinguishing them well you have to
justify why you're distinguishing them
and you're saying well we only use 3D
shapes in physics
do we do we use cubes perfect ideal
cubes is that part of the real world or
is that an imaginary thing cones uh
ideal cones of uh you know uh solids of
euclidean solids are those uh real
things perfect cone smooth not made out
of atoms are those part of the real
world
so no you cannot use you have to justify
why you're going to use form instead of
shape and not the other way around I
don't have to justify it
with that I'll see you next week if I
get here back in time otherwise I'm
going to have to postpone the next class
until I get back to Frankfurt we'll see
you then bye bye